uh that's good here we go all right hey
what's going on YouTube
you know apologizing is probably one of
the hardest things for people to do and
this brings especially truly to grew up
in an asian-american household for
instance in all the years that I have
been alive I have never ever heard my
father say the words oh I just saw deer
and straight up I don't think I'm sorry
is a phrase in the Asian American
culture we do have other phrases though
yeah this is you're good
why you do that one I have no son you
may not believe me but this [ __ ] goes
way back in time even in Japan back in
the day if one were to bring shame upon
themselves and their family they still
can do it I'm sorry was never enough
they would commit harakiri I'm still not
too sorry
but one time I heard my dad say I'm
sorry I think he did it on accident yeah
honey
oh you're so gay dude you're so [ __ ]
I don't know I feel like a lot of the
times to people especially when it comes
to older Asian men or even women
apologizing seems to be a sign of
weakness that if you admit fault
suddenly you are considered a submissive
human being but you do realize if you go
throughout your whole life without
apologizing you're basically saying that
you're an infallible human being which
by the way is the dumbest [ __ ] thing
on earth
do you honestly think that you have gone
throughout your whole life without
[ __ ] up once that you are so perfect
that your Dookie come out
diamond-encrusted to [ __ ] your [ __ ]
skidmark acting like you'll [ __ ] those
dick yeah [ __ ] you ate some spicy it
smells listen if you mess up you should
learn to apologize not because it makes
you look weak it's because the person
that you're apologizing to if they're
worth something to you they deserve to
hear it
listen recognizing when you're wrong
shows the possibility of growth nobody
is perfect I
when people can't admit that they're
wrong especially when you call them out
on the spot oh this room what about you
Shh yeah cuz y'all ever notice that when
you do call them out they start bringing
up [ __ ] that has nothing to do with the
fact that they [ __ ] up and that
they're wrong they will do or say
anything they can to make themselves
sound right dude you flaked on me
yesterday
well I died yesterday well that's kind
of inconvenient what the [ __ ] does that
have to do with something to happen
right now they always had to bring up
something that happened the past that
was already resolved as a [ __ ]
defense doesn't make sense just say
sorry and move out it's really not that
watch this I'm sorry oh my god did I
explode or dyin or my default God you
are alive one of the most ridiculous
things that I've heard from a friend is
that she said it is impossible for her
to apologize because it's too hard [ __ ]
you gave birth to a child and saying
sorry is the hardest thing on earth to
you what if you can shove a football out
your vagina and not walk like Bambi on
ice for the rest of your life you can
say sorry apologizing is easy just
recognize that you're wrong I screw up
and I apologize all the guy [ __ ] my
voice is out goddamn it what they got
don't apologize for his eating spicy
food and then fart another [ __ ] storm
that's your fault you got nostrils why'd
you breathe it in
yeah you are you are the gay you like a
culture you like a piece of a coyote Jay
I have another family in Korea I don't
have you your Korean name means a cancer
still no cure for dummies how are you my
daughter yeah just to come out the
project